you know there are no secrets anymore
the new york times which we all knew
bent over backwards to lean left is now
officially a leftist progressive
socialist newspaper there is no
objective journalism anymore
it is a newspaper for a certain mindset
only they as much as admitted it this
week when when their latest editorial
board hire sarah jong an asian woman is
outed for her cop hating caucasian
hating male hating social media messages
the grey lady responds with a what
difference does it make answer and the
washington post poo-poos the hate with
this namby-pamby headline is it okay to
make fun of white people online as if if
the police or we should kill all men is
humorous john has certainly given deeper
thought than most of us to hate filled
tweets and their consequences since you
yourself wrote a book about online
harassment now ask yourselves if any of
the following sound like comedy to you
cops are a-holes why don't we ever talk
about banning police f the police we
should kill all the men oh man
it's kind of sick how much joy I get out
of being cruel to old white men or
hashtag cancel white people f white
women now we're not just talking about a
writer for The Times we're talking about
an editorial board member an esteemed
and prestigious position at any
newspaper the editorial board is looked
up to for direction by journalists and
the newspaper that is always prided
itself on being there for the forgotten
and I'm being open-minded fair handed
and at the citadel of the newspaper
publishing world is now admitting to its
own hypocrisy by defending jeong they're
saying it's okay to be racist if your
target is white and they even say all
the outcry is over all tweets old tweets
as if three years ago is old and they
say as a young asian woman she's been
subject to online harassment as if
hating cops our whites is okay if you
say you've been harassed but even more
revealing is John's own statement that
her comments were not aimed at the
general audience pre tell saying if the
police is about as general an audience
as you can get in someone who has a job
at the New York Times as a wordsmith
should know the difference between a
specific and a general audience it's
specific when it's against one police
officer its general if it's against all
law enforcement and the whole group of
them you know the bigotry is alarming as
recently as a few weeks ago the New York
Times goaded its readers into an ad in
an editorial to fight the nomination of
the latest Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh quote to take a line
from The Godfather this is the New York
Times it's time to go to the mattresses
really The Godfather
now we've spent a while since I've seen
The Godfather but last I recall going to
the mattresses meant that one family was
going to wipe out another but you're not
surprised you already knew this didn't
you I'm tired of the elitist telling me
and everyone else to not believe our
lying eyes when the truth is so
painfully obvious whether it's Peter
struck saying he hated and despised
Trump and would stop his becoming
president but it did not affect his work
when he's the one who began the
counterintelligence investigation
against Trump that we are still living
with or Zhang's defenders saying there
is no evidence her tweets had any
bearing on her work it appears the old
gray lady is finally flipped her wig
time to go to the mattresses on a
Supreme Court justice really here's my
favorite quote from The Godfather we're
gonna make you an offer you can't refuse
stop your resistance stop your
obstruction stop the hypocrisy and get
on board with making America great again
or get the hell out of the way and
that's my open